NILKA THOMAS: All right.
So hi, everyone.
My name is Nilka Thomas.
And I'm a manager of diversity.
And I sit in the
New York office.
I am very fortunate to be
able to introduce Sylvia Ann
Hewlett, who's here today
speaking about her recently
published book, "Forget a
Mentor, Find a Sponsor."
So just quickly, what the
run of show is going to be,
we're going to
have Sylvia come up
and she's going to introduce
us to this distinction
between mentorship
and sponsorship,
and tell you how
sponsorship may be
your fastest ticket to the top.
Following her
presentation, we're
going to do a very brief Q&A
for about 15 or 20 minutes.
So in terms of introduction,
just very quickly,
Sylvia is an economist
and founder and CEO
of a New York-based
think tank called
the Center for
Talent Innovation.
She founded and
chaired a task force
for talent innovation for
75 multinational companies,
of which Google is one, that
are focused on fully realizing
the new streams of talent
in the global marketplace.
Sylvia is author of 10
"Harvard Business Review"
articles and 10 critically
acclaimed books including
"Off-ramps and On-ramps" as
well as "When the Bough Breaks."
She's no stranger to Google.
She's a longtime partner and
has been here many times before.
So today she is back
by popular demand.
Sylvia?
[APPLAUSE]
SYLVIA ANN HEWLETT: Well,
it is fabulous to be back.
And I want to begin
today with a little bit
about my own personal
journey because I
think I bring a particular
passion to this work
because it so much
resonates to my own life.
So I grew up in the
Welsh mining valleys,
a very neglected and rather
bleak part of the UK.
In fact, when I was growing
up, the local unemployment rate
was 38%.
The coal mines
were closing down.
And I was a part
of a working class
family that was six daughters.
I spent a lot of my
childhood praying for the boy
because my working class bloke
of a rather wonderful father
desperately wanted a son.
So when my mom was 45
years old and gave birth
to her sixth daughter,
she officially gave up.
And my dad decided he'd better
do something with his girls.
The most you could do as a
girl child in the Welsh mining
valleys was marry
an unemployed miner.
So not too appealing
in lots of ways.
So what he did when I
was 13 is he took me
by bus to Cambridge University.
And he basically
saw me, I think,
as a young person
with some promise.
And he knew what young people
of promise needed was a dream.
So he showed me
what he had heard
was one of the most beautiful
and opportunity-packed campuses
in Europe.
And he just said to me, if you
work hard, you can go here.
It was a very
audacious challenge
because I went to a
very lousy school which
had been in existence
for 200 years
and no one had ever been to
either Oxford or Cambridge.
So why should I be different?
But he had in the
back of his mind
a sense that times
were changing.
A women's movement was
getting off the ground.
And there was a Labor
government in power
which was forcing the
ancient universities
to open their doors much more
widely to some different folks,
in particular girls and
kids from the wrong side
of the tracks.
And I certainly got to
qualify on both those scores.
So I did go back to Wales.
Obviously, I worked like crazy.
I was very motivated.
But quite frankly,
I would not have
gotten into that
university had it not been
for the change of the rules,
the attitudes, and the culture.
And I think what I
learned from that
is that really no one,
no matter how promising,
really pulls themselves up
by their own bootstraps.
We all need heavy-duty
lifting from outside.
And this task force I
founded 10 years ago-- which
now has 75 companies and
it's wonderful to be working
with Google-- is really
about fully realizing
the talents of all the new
kids on the block, women,
multicultural folks,
gay individuals, folks
from emerging markets, Gen Ys.
Because many of us have
different value propositions.
We have different
things that incentivize
us, et cetera, et cetera.
And we cannot any longer
work with an old paradigm.
So let me share with you this
particular piece of work.
We've done some amazing work.
We did a whole study, for
instance, on extreme jobs.
How do you make
them sustainable?
What is an extreme job?
We did a huge study last year on
what we call the power of out.
What happens when
gay individuals can
claim their full
identity at work?
And in Silicon Valley, only
43% of gay professionals
are actually out in the
workplace, a rather staggering
thought.
So we look at the talent
issues right across the gamut.
And this is the task force.
We have some
extraordinary members.
It's very global.
We see the talent conversation
as a global conversation
and not an American
conversation.
So we have Genpak, and
we have [INAUDIBLE].
We have all kinds of players.
A recent addition, which
is a strange addition, some
of the multilateral
institutions are
joining us, the
IMF for instance,
which desperately needs
to diversify, and the CIA.
We're not quite sure
why the CIA joined.
It's all classified.
But we suspect that they
know that if they're
going to be effective
in this world,
they better do a better
job of reflecting
the face of their
mission and sending
a bunch of 50-year-old pale
males to some of the arenas
that they're in as
leaders ain't gonna work.
So they're trying to learn
from the private sector, which
is fascinating.
And actually the numbers
show that the private sector
is doing better than the public
sector in all kinds of ways
in terms of these
talent changes.
So these are some of
the companies that
underwrote this
particular piece of work.
And what I'm going
to start with here
is the challenge behind this
piece of work on sponsorship.
So here's the deal.
There's been enormous progress
in the lower and middle rungs
of career ladders.
But life at the top hasn't
changed much at all.
For instance, one figure I
feel is indicative of it all,
only 8% of the top earners
in this economy are female.
That figure was precisely
the same 15 years ago.
So there's been all
this change in what
I call the marzipan layer,
that rich but very sticky
layer below the top, but not a
whole lot of change at the top.
And people of color are
also stuck and stalled
at the middle levels.
So what we did was
try and figure out
how people got to the top.
And it's about how power is
transferred in the workplace.
And basically what has
happened through time--
and we're not newly
discovering this,
we're just newly
quantifying it--
senior leaders have
replicated themselves.
They've tapped on the shoulder
someone in the next level
down who they feel
most comfortable with.
Whether they went to school,
they behave the same,
they maybe go to the
same church or synagogue,
there is a comfort zone.
Leadership replicates itself.
So the idea is to actually
describe what's going on
and make it more
accessible to folks
who didn't necessarily come
from sponsor-rich environments.
Folks like me.
There weren't too many leaders
in those valleys I grew up in.
So in our data we
find that there
are three things a sponsor
does that really distinguishes
this person from a mentor,
an old-style mentor.
First off, the
leader really needs
to know you, needs to
understand your value,
and be willing to
take a bet on you.
Because you'll be walking
around with their brand
on your forehead.
So you've got to be
able to grow this
as an organic,
work-driven relationship.
It's got to be real.
Secondly, that person who
is almost by definition
a more senior person
in the organization
needs to publicly advocate
for that next position,
for that next
stretch opportunity
so that you can show your
promise to the world.
And finally, they have
to be in your corner
so you can take some risks
because nothing gets done
that's amazing in the workplace
without a great deal of risk
and therefore failure.
It's often said, for
instance, that people of color
are risk averse at work.
We find that that's not true.
They're merely not suicidal.
So few of them have
sponsors, so few of them
have a senior person that has
their back, that it's actually
very dangerous to take a risk.
So that's the third
thing that a sponsor
does that is extremely important
in terms of your traction.
Now the stuff on
the right is stuff
that sponsors do but
mentors often do,
too-- the guidance, the
contacts, the advice.
I mean, that's something
that has always
been on offer in
progressive companies.
Turning to the other
side of the equation,
one of the big, distinguishing
realities about the sponsorship
relationship is that
it's deeply reciprocal.
You almost have to
give before you get.
In other words, you need
to earn sponsorship.
How do you do it?
What makes it very likely
that you are the person who
will get tapped on the
shoulder for this opportunity?
Well, again, in the data
there are three things.
First up, performance,
of course.
That's central.
Trustworthiness,
loyalty to the team,
to the leader because
no one is going
to take a bet on you unless
you're incredibly reliable.
Thirdly, you better
have some currency
that makes you create
value-added, something
that the leader does
not have, something
that the team does not have.
I mean, it could be
cultural fluency.
It could be amazing
knowledge of-- I
don't know-- the New Jersey
market or a third language.
Name it, it's out there.
Figuring out your currency,
lifting it up, shouting it
from the rooftops, making
it apparent what's additive,
what's unique about
your contribution,
enormously powerful
in terms of making
you indispensable to leaders.
So what we're describing
here is something
which is very profoundly
a two-way street.
And this, of course, is very
different from mentoring.
Because traditional mentoring
is a very passive thing.
I mean, what does a mentee do?
They sit.
They smile.
They say, thank you.
They take some notes, perhaps.
Make an appointment for
coffee in two months.
But you don't have
skin in the game.
It's something that's
being given to you.
It's paying it forward.
Probably you'll all
do it, whether it's
interns that are in the
office for the summer.
Or in my case, I've
got endless students
that I have mentored
over the years.
What we find is that
when there is confusion
as to what is mentoring
and what is sponsorship,
you can get the balance
wrong in your life.
For instance, we find
that women and people
of color over-mentor.
It's very easy to have
17 people that you're
mentoring because there
is such a yearning
for that kind of support.
But unless you're also
sponsoring two or three
people who are fabulous and
really delivering for you,
you stall out.
We find leaders who
sponsor well are much more
likely to get the
next, more senior slot.
It propels them forward.
People who become
isolated and don't sponsor
don't have this kind of powerful
posse of younger folks shoving
and pushing and helping you.
So what we say
about this research
is that any point
in your career you
should be doing
both things, seeking
to refresh your sponsors to
get yourself to the next level
and proactively investing
in just two or three
people on your team, perhaps,
who you value particularly
and you have very high
expectations of in terms
of what they deliver for you.
And then, obviously,
the pay it forward
and the gift of mentoring
you can also do,
but not exclusively.
So I want to just tell
one story about why
it's important to sponsor
really from a pretty
early age in the workplace.
One of the powerful
interviews I did for this book
was with the head of an
engineering firm on the East
Coast.
So he said, I totally get
this sponsoring thing.
When I interview
people who have gone
through the whole
selection process
and are being considered as
one of my direct reports,
I will always ask
this key question
which is, how many people
do you have in your pocket?
Meaning, how many people that
you sponsored over the years
and are now dotted around
this company in key positions?
So if I asked you to do
something totally impossible
next week which involved
liaising across three
geographies and
five functions, you
could actually deliver because
there are folks out there who
owe you one, and
think you're fabulous,
and would put your
project first.
And he said, I'm not
interested in any one
who doesn't have deep pockets.
And these days,
given our global span
and the face of our
consumer, they'd
better be deep, diverse pockets.
And of course, we might
not choose that language.
But it is a deeply productive
alliance with a senior person.
This is not meant to
be a burden on anyone.
And it's muscles that we
need to develop and flex
if we are going
to be successful.
OK, so let's look at the data.
The data rests on four different
surveys, representative samples
of mid-level and senior
executives across this economy.
We also did a ton of
online focus groups
which were anonymous,
and a lot of interviews.
So if you look
across the economy,
obviously not everyone
will get sponsors
because it is the
leadership track.
It is the fast track.
So 19% of men, in
general, get sponsorship.
The thing is that men,
particularly white men,
are much more likely to have
this relationship at work
than women or people of color.
The gap on the ethnic background
front is particularly wide.
As you can see, Caucasians 63%
more likely to have a sponsor.
And we find that
the stickler here--
remember that second
thing that goes on?
This trust, this reliability,
this loyalty thing?
It seems that trust, the sense
that you can really, totally
rely on this person to
come through for you,
doesn't cross lines of
gender or race very readily.
It has to be something that
is learned, that is a goal,
is something that's
sought after.
Because the natural
tendency is a mini me thing.
You select and groom
for leadership someone
who is in your
prime comfort zone.
OK, so we're looking
at what sponsors
do in terms of our data.
Did we find that this
is pretty dramatic data?
Men and women with
sponsors, much more likely
to ask for and get a pay raise.
Well, why not?
There's someone on
that committee deciding
on bonuses or pay grades
who is speaking out for you.
Secondly, men and women
with sponsors much more
likely to stick around.
And again, why not?
There's someone who's giving
you career opportunities, who's
telling you that you've got
what it takes, that you're
valuable to the company,
et cetera, et cetera.
But think of this figure.
Women who've just had
a child are 38% more
likely to both come back
to work and stay back
at work if they have a sponsor.
So the impact is huge.
And then it impacts ambition.
And we find, for instance,
the 35-year-olds,
38-year-olds do not
downsize their dreams
if they're sponsored.
They're able to sustain their
ambition through midlife.
Because again, there's traction.
They can see that
there's a pathway where
they are advancing with really
important folks on their side.
And finally, the progression
figures are extremely clear.
And remember in this data we're
using the definition that I
shared with you.
And it is this rather
rigorous definition
of what this senior
person is doing for you
and what you're doing for them.
But right across
the board, there's
a huge impact of
sponsorship on whether you
get to the next
rung on the ladder.
OK, let's talk about
some of the tripwires
because obviously
it's not a coincidence
that particularly women and
multicultural folks somehow
miss out on this relationship.
So let's talk about
the first tripwire.
Again, leaders often
tell us in the research
they find it hard to choose
a woman because somehow she
is not seen as a
potential leader.
She isn't seen as
leadership material.
And there's all this
silly stuff going on.
In other words, there's
this very narrow window
of what is deemed acceptable
in the leadership model.
So it's awfully easy
for a woman to be
seen as too
opinionated, too bossy.
The B word comes out.
Or she's seen as too quiet,
too retiring, too passive.
Just a little window
where she's just right.
And we find that
if a man is quiet,
he's seen as a still waters run
deep type, all kinds of stuff
going on there.
He's just not sharing.
A woman is just seen as
probably just not up to snuff.
On dress, too
provocative, too frumpy.
I had a CEO give me a whole
lecture about the frump
factor in his company and how
distressing it was to him.
Too aggrandizing, we
can be too show-offy.
We are too pushy.
Or we're too self-depreciating.
And then the one I love, we're
too young or we're too old.
There's three years in
there when we're just right.
Men get 17 years.
So I'll tell you what those
three years are afterwards.
But more seriously, I
think what that data--
and I wish I could
say it was old data.
It's not old data.
It's like a year ago.
What it shows is the
needs-- and probably Google
is rather good at this--
expanding our vision of what
leaders look like, talk
like, and behave like.
Because to use those kinds
of implicit screening devices
is a ridiculous notion
because obviously it
has so little to do with the
performance or the contribution
of individuals.
But this is distressing.
35% of African
American individuals
in the middle levels
of their companies
feel that it is impossible
to get to the top.
And it has a huge impact on
behavior because we find--
and this is a real figure-- 43%
of very high potential, valued,
long track record, African
American individuals
at age 40-ish leave for
entrepreneurial activities.
They do not stay in
corporations because of that.
They assume that they're
on a slow road to nowhere.
OK, so what we have done--
and this is very much what
the book's about--
you don't need
a program or some
massive initiative.
I mean, companies
can help by creating
a culture of sponsorship perhaps
by helping you create pathways
to sponsorship.
But it's also true
that as an individual
you can go make this
happen for yourself.
So there is a journey.
There are tactics.
There are things you have to
have centrally in your mind.
And one thing I do
want to just point out
is that we absolutely
need to be operating
on both sides of this
equation all the time.
So let me pick out a
couple of these things
because you do have the
book, so all of it's there.
First off, as you
figure out which
of the kind of power
brokers in your life
might be the one to get in front
of and impress the hell out of,
you can't make that
decision until you
know where you're going.
So creating this vision of
the kind of agency, impact,
and influence, and position
that you might ultimately want
is a pretty important exercise.
And one story which I love
which stuck in my mind, when
Walt Disney built that amazing
theme park in Florida all
those years ago-- I
think it was 1967--
he knew he had to
build the castle first.
Because that's
where the magic is.
So that's what he did.
There was this
medieval fantasy castle
with the turrets and the flags.
And for the 30,000
workers who were
grappling with the
mangrove swamps
and trying to build those
tunnels and lakes and all
the rest of it, it was
pretty amazing to know
what they were building and
this kind of paradise for kids
that it was going to be.
And it was a huge reason for why
engagement was incredibly high
and that project was
delivered on time, on budget.
So build your castle first.
Career journeys are full of
difficult chunks of time.
To maintain one's
motivation, one's,
I guess, focus, one's
drive, one's vision,
it's pretty important to be
able to embrace and touch
and almost smell the role
that you ultimately want.
So I just want to pick
out a couple of things.
When you scan the horizon
for some possible sponsors,
there's some classic
mistakes people make.
You do not need to look for
someone who looks like you
or acts like you.
We find one thing
that is very true,
particularly of women,
is that they seek out
collaborative leaders, leaders
that are inclusive, leaders
that value push-back,
all that kind of stuff.
And they love it if that leader
also happens to be a woman.
But what do you imagine
you need to in a sponsor?
Because you can
find role models.
You can find mentors.
What do you really,
really need in a sponsor?
Does any of that stuff matter?
Does it matter?
AUDIENCE: No.
SYLVIA ANN HEWLETT: No?
What we say is that
you need someone
who has a voice on the
decision-making table that
affects you going down the line.
You need someone
who has the power
to make a difference
in your career.
Now you need to
respect that person.
You need to think that they are
amazingly good at what they do.
But you don't need to like them.
You probably have to understand
that they have integrity.
But this is a
transactional relationship.
As one key leader told me,
he said, I don't do empathy.
That's what these other
relationships are for.
Find a friend or a mentor.
Don't confuse these two things.
Because when we
do this research,
we find that many
women are looking
for this particular
personality that they can super
relate to, who's
married with kids.
So you've got your pool
down to about 1% of leaders.
In other words,
you're so restricting
the potential
candidates for this.
So see it as an alliance where
you totally join missions,
if you like, and you
both forge ahead.
Don't treat it as something
that's full of, as I said,
empathy.
Let me also just emphasize
the last thing on this list,
leading with a yes.
And maybe this is so obvious
in the Google environment.
But we found again one
thing that sponsors totally
require is this kind
of gung-ho, leaping
at opportunities
kind of attitude.
And again, a little story, a
CFO who I spent a lot of time
with in interviews
for this book,
he was trying to figure out
who to throw his weight behind,
as he put it, in terms of
selecting the person who
would take over his role.
He was retiring.
And there were nine finalists
because there always
are a lot of candidates, whether
it's official or unofficial,
for any sought after position.
And the one he really
felt he wanted to support
was the only woman on the list.
He knew her well.
He'd sponsored her.
But for this
particular position,
because it was a
big leap for her,
he wasn't sure she
was hungry enough.
So he gave her a test.
He walked into her office
one Monday morning and said,
Janet, do I have an
opportunity for you.
I need someone to go
to Omaha for six weeks
and troubleshoot this client.
The whole thing is
falling to pieces.
We're losing a lot
of money, et cetera.
Take a team in and fix it.
So Janet looked up from her
desk and said, fantastic.
When do I start?
Now the next morning,
she remembered
she had a one-year-old
and a few other clients,
a few other
responsibilities in life.
And she went back and she
re-negotiated the terms.
She was still white hot.
She still totally felt she could
do it and was going to do it.
It was not that she was going
back with second thoughts.
But she said, look, let me
go in for four-day spurts.
I've got all these
other things going on.
I'll put my number two there.
We'll handle it.
And he was thrilled.
Because, he said,
actually that's
what anyone would have done.
No one worth their
salt can really
go to Omaha for six weeks.
You better have some other
important things in your life.
And it would be
what anyone would
do who was really
an A candidate.
But he said so many
women in his experience
would lead with
ambivalence, would
be way too honest about how
they couldn't do it perfectly.
They would wring
their hands and talk
about the one-year-old
and stuff like that.
He said, bad idea.
If you have ambivalence,
share it with your mentor.
Your sponsor needs to
understand that you want this.
So again, some lessons.
I mean, the number of mistakes
I've made in my career
are legion.
I wish I'd had this
data when I was 30.
The roadmap for
sponsors is fascinating
because it has a lot to do
with profoundly understanding
what's in it for you.
And one thing we find
in this is very tricky.
Asian Americans, women,
people from other countries
oftentimes don't sponsor at all.
Why do you imagine
they don't sponsor?
AUDIENCE: Because they
haven't been sponsored?
SYLVIA ANN HEWLETT: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: They haven't
been sponsored.
SYLVIA ANN HEWLETT: They don't
understand the game in a way,
right.
But they feel that it's
sticking their neck out.
And who would they sponsor?
If they sponsored someone like
them, that would be risky,
they think.
That there will
be such scrutiny.
A Brazilian sponsoring
a Brazilian?
Or a woman sponsoring another
woman in a small team?
So they shrink from doing that.
And yet, that is the thing
that they would like to do.
And oftentimes they
don't sponsor anyone.
So there were lots of
stories of heartache
as they turned away
from sponsorship.
And it's one reason why
they tend to over-mentor.
Because that is very risk-free.
But it does mean that they
dissipate a lot of energy
because no one should
have 27 mentees.
That's a silly thing to do.
It really undermines
your own power
if you're giving
that kind of time.
So again, there
is a huge learning
in-- so those who
have proteges, again,
much more likely to progress.
So there's just one
last thing I want
to share before opening it up
to questions, a piece of work
that we have just finished.
It's called "Innovation,
Diversity, and Market Growth."
It's coming out in the
[INAUDIBLE] next month.
It's a huge study of
14 sectors, 40 case
examples, all kinds of data.
What we are able to
do in this new work
is show precisely how the
power of difference on teams
unlocks innovation
and drives growth.
So let me just go into it
a little bit because it's
why we need to care about
why we should progress
a fair representation
of individuals who cover
the spectrum of difference
in terms of identity,
in terms of experience,
in terms of perspective.
So at the core of this work, we
looked very hard at diversity.
What is it?
We discovered there are
two kinds that really
matter when it
comes to innovation.
First off, you need a certain
amount of inherent diversity.
By inherent, I mean baked in,
the stuff you're born with.
You're a woman or a man.
Your sexual identity is
a certain way, et cetera.
Or you grew up as an Asian
person, et cetera, et cetera.
We have eight dimensions of
diversity that are inherent,
that are immutable.
And you need at least some
of that around the table.
Because otherwise you do not see
certain market opportunities,
that there is not a visceral
connect to unmet needs,
to unexplored opportunities
in the market.
But in addition to that you
need what we call acquired
diversity, which is a bunch
of behaviors that create
a speak-up culture, make it
safe to put out-of-the-box ideas
that maybe the leaders are
incredibly unfamiliar with
on the table.
Because obviously, if you
come from a very different
background or got a very
different disciplinary or skill
set, you are putting
stuff on the table
that is not familiar to leaders.
So these attributes of
acquired diversity--
and there are five behaviors
that particularly count-- are
the other ingredient.
So the fabulous thing
is that companies
that have both things going
on, both the inherent diversity
and the acquired
diversity, really
do unlock market
share and market
growth because they are
much better at innovation.
It's the kind of
talent conditions
that you like for
innovation to happen.
And then the vast
majority of companies
don't have one or the other.
Maybe both.
But one doesn't
do it because you
can have a team that's
most impressively diverse.
But if you have a command
and control bully culture,
all of that's going
to remain latent.
It does not express itself.
So this new study,
go to my website.
It's all very available.
It was published last month.
It is a fantastic
study, I think,
in terms of why we
need to care, in terms
of creating the kind
of wonderful diversity
that we have in this room
around the leadership
tables of this country.
So I'll leave it at that.
And I would like to
take some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
It does.
I guess I'm going
wider than that.
Obviously, individuals who
are in management roles
should be particularly
self-aware on this front
and understand the power of both
looking up and looking down,
and making sure you have
these vital relationships.
But it's certainly not
limited to managers.
It's the way to forge success.
And it's true for
entrepreneurs, too,
because what do
entrepreneurs need?
They need power brokers.
They need to finance.
They need people to
believe in their ideas.
They need people to back them.
It's true of life.
One thing that I
feel very strongly
is what I learned
from this research,
because obviously I'm
at a point in life
where I'm not necessarily
climbing the ladder anymore.
So this is how it changed
my behavior, this research.
First off, it made me
very mindful of sponsoring
very deliberately two or
three particularly outstanding
younger people, and
not over-mentoring,
which is a danger in my life.
I'm a professor
in my spare time.
And the number of
folks who want me
to write them recommendations
and that kind of thing.
And I certainly do a
certain amount of it.
But what I found
was that I was not
making the deliberate
investments in younger people
who could contribute enormously
to my agency and my influence.
But the other thing
I learned is that I
figured that I needed
my next castle.
You always need your
next castle unless you're
85 and really checking out.
So what was my next castle?
So I thought about that.
And I realized I
had another castle.
And I wanted to have more
influence in public policy.
It was a place I'd started.
It matters to me.
I'd just done this amazing
work for the private sector.
And I wanted to
have more influence.
So I dusted off my Rolodex
or my contact list, whatever.
And I looked for who
I knew in Washington
who could open doors.
I was looking for a
new kind of sponsor.
So I realized I knew someone
from 13 years ago who's
currently head of the Council
of Economic Advisers, someone
called Alan Kreuger.
And I called him.
I did a bunch of homework.
And I learned from my own
research how to approach this.
So I called up Alan and I
said, Alan, how can I help you?
Can I deliver some value?
I know you're doing X, Y,
and Z. And I have this work.
And this is what I
could do for you.
He nearly fell of his seat.
He was so thrilled.
Most calls from old friends
are really asking for favors.
So don't do that.
Figure out what you can
give that is valuable.
And so I did do a
bunch of stuff for him.
And sponsorship flowed.
He opened a whole
bunch of doors.
I ended up on an
advisory committee.
I got what I, in the
end, really wanted out
of this relationship.
I mean, not that I begrudged
the stuff I was doing for him.
But I learned so much
from this research
in terms of as a protege
in this situation,
how to make that happen.
So there is something magical
about just the mindset which
is not just limited to managers.
Well, that's what the
roadmap really is all about.
And there are also
a bunch of tactics
how you get in front of folks
because that is an issue.
Because you could be already
with a most extraordinary
stream of value,
but how do you get
to first base kind of thing?
So there are various tactics.
In many organizations,
you can ask for a mentor.
And be careful and clever
in terms of who you ask for.
Because that's seen as
a pretty light fingered,
easy thing to do.
And then turn it
into sponsorship
by using a very deliberate,
intentional strategy of vesting
energies.
Another thing which
really works is
that if there's professional
associations or ERGs, or even
local not-for-profit boards
that many of your leaders
are involved in do
some major piece
of investing in your community.
And that's a very good way
to showcase your emerging
leaderly kind of
qualities and to get
to know some much more
senior folks as peers.
And, again, you can't fake it.
You have to choose something
you're genuinely interested in
because it makes
no sense otherwise.
But again, if we look
at the strategies
that pay off-- the
book is full of them--
there are some
very simple things
that can bring off the
initial connection.
You certainly should not
turn up at someone's office
that you don't know and
say, will you sponsor me?
I mean, that is
not going to work
because they have
to believe in you.
Because they're taking a risk.
And they have skin in the game.
I think most white male leaders
are not trying to avoid you.
It's just that in
their line of sight
it's easier to make the
choices that they typically
have done in the past.
Much of it's subliminal.
No, not at all, especially,
I think, on this campus.
AUDIENCE: So what
are those years?
SYLVIA ANN HEWLETT: Well, across
the economy, it's 38 to 41.
You've got a big
runway in front of you.
[APPLAUSE]